buenas tardes pues más que un debate
electoral esto casi parece un partido de
fútbol por la explotación que se puede
sentir en la calle los coches llegando
antes a sus casas todo el mundo
expectante de este debate que va a ser
esencial uno de los más claves de la
democracia chilena uno de los también
que se espera sea más tenso en cuanto a
las posiciones de los candidatos se han
modificado tanto desde la primera vuelta
que podríamos decir que son propuestas
completamente diferentes de un lado el
ultraderechista santo no cas que
proponía en un principio eliminar el
ministerio de la mujer y proponía
también subvenciones especiales para
mujeres casadas con respecto a mujeres
solteras divorciadas u otras ahora dice
que no va a eliminar ese ministerio de
la mujer y que va a incorporar programas
de de género y también que se debería
incluir más mujeres en el caso de que
resultara ganador en el gabinete entre
sus ministros del otro lado gabriel
boric que pasó durante muchos años como
diputado criticando la labor de la
concertación de los partidos de
centroizquierda se ha acercado mucho a
la centroizquierda en las últimas
semanas en unas posiciones mucho más
moderadas ha incluido también de
factores como la segura la lucha contra
el narcotráfico la estabilidad económica
la delincuencia en su programa para
atraer a un electorado mucho más de
centro bueno justamente en este contexto
hay polémica por la reunión que
sostuvieron el aspirante y ex líder
estudiantil gabriel gabriel boric y la
ex presidenta chilena y alta comisionada
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet cast criticó que el encuentro
haya sido solo con su contrincante como
se interpreta esta reunión
bueno la posición de michelle bachelet
es bastante clara para todos ella es una
figura todavía muy influyente en la
ciudadanía chilena que puede determinar
un gran factor de los votantes todavía
indecisos ella ha viajado al país ya la
fundación que estaba que ella fundó en
su momento de ciudad horizonte horizonte
ciudadano y entregó su su postura
oficial a favor del candidato boric y el
hecho de que se haya reunido deja todo
el mundo muy claro cuál es su posición
política aunque ella no puede realizar
ningún tipo de valoración pública debido
a su cargo en la onu es muy clara cuál
es un poco la para todos los ciudadanos
la postura y esto ha generado muchísima
tensión del lado del ultraderechista cas
que tiene miedo a los votos que se
pueden escapar en ese sector hay que
decir también que el voto de la mujer
será muy influyente en las próximas
elecciones y también muchas podrían
e inclinarse un poco hacia este sentido